[Music]
i come from a family of
six children if i was the oldest
yeah in between us there was a brother
ryan and after me my mother had twins
but uh one of them died her name was
freda
then is jude and a little brother yanka
and we lived a very happy life my father
was a businessman
and we were educated in chechit and in
yiddish we had a yeshiva in the town
that we supported we never experienced
any anti-semitism under the czech
government
we associated my friends were czech
you know so we had a very happy home
life
the hungarian army came in and then they
occupied the cafe
they took our business away they just
plain blind came in and they occupied
them
and they told you get out and that was
it
[Music]
there was like rumbling uh rows of tanks
were coming through the town and they
parked those things
in the center and we heard those noises
during the night
in the morning there was a knock on our
door and there were two assassins
standing and he said let's go
towards the end they started to
liquidate the ghetto
they started to ship people out event
like they ship animals you know those
open trains
they never opened up the cars it never
stopped
it just constantly was going
and we were suffocated practically there
and because there were so many people
crammed into a small place there was no
water
people were fainting elderly people were
dying
and finally after three days of
traveling
the train suddenly stopped and suddenly
opened up the doors
and i heard they say that man here this
goes here
the people's house was going with those
rubber sticks you know here there and we
were very scared and we didn't know
nothing i remember my father
was grab my brother you know and my
mother the food of the five the five
kids my mother and me my sister we were
holding together
and as we come down they were the ss
pushed my father here
and we go here and my mother
was going with me when my sister and
there was eight ten eleven they pushed
it here
and i remember my my mother the kids
thought hi mommy mommy you know and my
mother
pulled herself away from me and she says
[ __ ]
you should take care of your sister like
a viewer the minute we stepped off the
freight train we were separated right
there and then
my father and my older brother went on
one side
my sister she was a tall girl so they
made her go to one side and i went with
my mother
and with the uh younger children
and my mother looked around and she says
well where's
your sister i said they made her go over
there so she tells me
you run after her because she only has
one dress on her
and they pushed her on one side and i
was running
from one place to another and i don't
know how
because in auschwitz you just didn't run
from one place to another
but somehow i caught up with her and i
found her
and we were marching you know they took
us
into a section where all the women
arrivals
came in and that was a big long
barrett and you stay there we were in
auschwitz for three days in barracks
and outside all that going down there
was a big band
playing music constantly day and night
there was smoke heavy smoke there were
babies screaming people looking where
it's come from
but you couldn't see where it's come
from everybody was screaming and crying
and running
and and they said you know don't cry
you'll be after they go shower and
they'll you'll meet them and afternoon
they'll meet again is since then that
was the last time we started
my father my brother my grandmother my
mother
and my younger brother that was the last
time i've seen them
i had never heard of anything about my
rest of the family until one day i was
sitting by the window i was mending the
socks
and this friend of mine walks into the
room and he said to me yeah
sylvia what are you going to give me i
have a surprise for you
and i picked up my head and i saw my
sister standing in the yard you know in
the courtyard
so first i thought i was singing things
and then she gave a yell and i ran out
in the courtyard
and we both fainted right there in the
[Music]
spot
you